[музика]
вітаємо вас це програма У фокусі Європи
компанії Deutsche Welle Україна святкує
частковий успіх у війні проти російських
загарбників стратегічно важливе місто
Херсон на півдні країни знову вільне
жителі захоплено зустрічають українських
військових які після відступу росіян
заходять до Херсона
[музика]
місяцями Люди страждали під російською
окупацією
український уряд оголосив про звільнення
інших окупованих територій
звільнено від російських військ також і
територію на сході України в районі
міста Вовчанськ
однак Вовчанський здебільшого нагадує
зараз місто привид
лише через численні воєнні руйнування
оскільки війна ще близько
але тому що мешканці який відкрито
симпатизували росіянам утекли
залишився Сергій Коновалов він радить що
і місто знову під контролем української
армії
але він знає що злагода і мир
повернуться до рідного міста ще не скоро
дорога до вовчанська займає 5 годин
зараз вона утричі довше ніж до війни
оскільки мости та дороги зруйновані з
обласного центру Харкова доводиться
їхати об'їзними дорогами до війни тут
проживало 17 тисяч жителів звідси до
російського кордону всього чотири
кілометри
російська армія окупувала вовчанську у
перший день війни
у вересні Україна відвоювала місто
вісім місяців окупації весь цей час
Сергій Коновалов перебував у місті він
називає окупантів рашистами це слово
складене з двох основ росіяни і фашисти
до цього поки щости не пройшли в мене
було все робота
жінка була
одіта обута в холодильник повний Що не
так
а не пройшли просто зіпсували нам життя
і вовчанська немає вовчанська роз'їхався
весь
[музика]
наразі більшість жителів втекли скрізь
сліди боїв
зараз місто контролюють українські
військові На в'їзді в місто стоять
блок-пости вони побоюються що Росія
зашла туди диверсантів Але перед усім
Росія посилає сюди снаряди випущені по
інший бік кордону
вони обстрілюють нас в основному що
понеділка
вони бомблять великі міста в понеділок
вранці і таким же чином бажаю Доброго
ранку всім нам
сліди обстрілів тут усюди постійно
відключається електроенергія газу більше
немає позаяк місто щодо війни під'єднали
до Російської газової системи
Люди готуються до холодної зими без
опалення через погані дороги у віддалену
місцевість рідко надходить також і
гуманітарно допомога
тому деокупації радіють тут не всі
янами ми певною мірою жили нормально
10 дней получала була робота ми
регулярно отримували гуманітарну
допомогу кожні 10 днів вони роздавали
також гроші а зараз немає взагалі нічого
а вибачте
місто ще до війни вважали проросійським
коли росіяни пішли багато жителів втекли
Разом із ними за оцінками адміністрації
залишились не більше п'ятої частини
населення в основному люди похилого віку
і ті хто не має Діла до руського мира
під росіянами нам жилося погано
по вулицях ходили російські фашисти
і раніше
дві жінки відтягують п'яного чоловіка
а тому що ви завтра зробите з нас
колаборантів
недовіра у місті велика хто співпрацював
з окупантами
А хто можливо й досі передає їм
інформацію навіть сьогодні військові
адміністрації не легко
ми постійно чуємо що дехто намагається
сидіти на двох стільцях Спочатку вони
доносили на людей росіянам сьогодні вони
приходять до нас і звинувачують інших
успіх праці
як і всюди росіяни панували насильно у
підвалах окупантів зникали передусім
молоді чоловіки дехто повернувся з
важкими пораненнями одну з камер тортур
знайшли на цій фабриці
під приціл окупантів потрапив також і
Сергій його схопили на вулиці після
комендантської години і викликали до
себе
я думав мене тут будуть далі катувати чи
щось зі мною робити просто не знаю
я приходив о восьмій ранку і до 5 вечора
я був тут
копав щось щось переносив щось тягали
пісок мішки отаке все
заселяли мене тягати
Сергій вивіз із міста свою дружину та
маленьку доньку зараз він допомагає мамі
підготуватися до зими
потім теж хочу виїхати хоча б тимчасово
ми на своїй землі до нас прийшли на
землю не ми до когось зайшли От я так
читаю Я не знаю я думаю так і в ноги хто
щитає і українці так считають що ми на
своїй землі Ми не до кого не лізли нам
чужого не надо
черговий артилерійський залп із іншого
боку кордону навіть не в понеділок
4 роки тому справа джамалія харшогжі
викликали резонанс у всьому світі
журналіст який був одним з
найжорстокіших критиків режиму
Саудівської Аравії жорстоко вбили у
консульці Саудівської Аравії Стамбулі
його тіло безслідно зникло тоді
зруйнувався світлі турецької нареченої
хатіджес обоє хотіли одружитися проте
вбивство їхніх прибічників досі не
притягнули до відповідальності
не хоче миритися з тим що злочин проти
її колишнього супутника життя
залишається безкарним вона бореться за
справедливість
мене приймає жаль аджемал був Надією
а він був частиною мого життя моєї
особистості
і те що я втратила його таким чином
повністю Змінила моє життя
[музика]
Хатідже з не часто відвідує консульство
Саудівської Аравії у Стамбулі це місце
її лякає з того самого дня У жовтні
2018-го коли тут убили джамаля хашу
відомого саудівського дисидента тоді ще
нареченого Хатідже
ми прийшли сюди тому що нам потрібні
були деякі документи для нашого весілля
Він зайшов у середину А я чекала надворі
я чекала і чекала
і він просто не повернувся
коли я постукала потім у двері мені
відчинив чоловік і сказав тут нікого
немає
поки Хатідже чекала на вулиці
Саудівській Агенти жорстоко вбили
джемаля харшоп G а його тіло
розчленували
його змусили замовкнути бо він був
критичним журналістом
[музика]
зараз біля консульства стоїть пам'ятники
з білого каменю на ньому є ім'я Джамала
але цей пам'ятник не надгробний бо його
останки й досі не знайшли
вони його просто знищили але я постійно
ставлю це питання собі де його тіло що
сталося з його цілим з того самого дня я
борюся я борюся за справедливість для
Джамала
навесні 2018 року хатіджей Джамал
познайомились під час однієї конференції
вони швидко зблизились ці миті Я ніколи
не забуду я сказала собі тепер це моє
нове життя і з цим чоловіком сповнене
кохання із джамалом
[музика]
цього таки не трапилось через кілька
місяців Джамала вбила Хатідже досі
спустошена втратою
Тож вона зрештою прийняла рішення яке
дасть їй життю новий напрямок
я подумала Я не можу більше мовчати
треба щось робити
і з того дня все змінилося
я звернулась до громадськості і говорю
те що ніхто інший не говорить правду
мої слова моя сила
катідже почала подорожувати світом А
вона дала свідчення перед конгресом США
перед Європейським парламентом перед
радою Овни з прав людини
розслідування ООН знаходиться докази
того що відповідальність за вбивство
джамаля хашу керівництво Саудівської
Аравії
за даними американської розвідки
вбивство схвалив наслідний принц
Мухаммед Бін Салман він це Заперечує
[музика]
певний час Хатідже була впевнена що
справедливість переможе
поки не дізналась що означає реальна
політика
у неспокійному світі який жадає
енергетичних ресурсів а злочинці можуть
знову стати партнерами
судове провадження припинили і
справедливість щодо джамаляха щоб Джим
можливо не буде встановлена ніколи
я не могла цього зрозуміти це реальна
політика мене це дуже рочарувало Усі
знають що це політичні рішення
пари на березі босфору нагадують Хатідже
про її втрату але також і про істину що
Життя варте того щоб жити що варто
відстоювати справедливість
У мене є завдання і велика
відповідальність я повинна нагадувати
людям про те що зробили з Джамали
політологиня яка стала правозахисницею
Хатідже знайшла у своєму житті новий
сенс говорити за тих кого змусили
замовкнути слухати тих кого не чують
говори чітко для нашого майбутнього Нам
потрібно більше людяності більше
демократії більше прав людини Ніколи не
здавайся це моє послання
[музика]
Зараз ми познайомимо вас із справді
щасливими свинями із закрученими в
облаком хвостами вони належать ті мохелю
він володіє найбільшою Фінляндії
свинячою фермою і вважає що немає нічого
гіршого ніж відгодівля свиней які
вимушені жити з лиденним життям у тісних
стінах та напів темряві тому він стежить
за тим щоб його стінах було достатньо
місця і щоб його поросята були здоровими
Він хоче щоб тварини на його фермі в
русском на заки від Гельсінки були
просто задоволеними
це не якийсь там милі поросятка це
поросята Тімо Хей кіля і йому Важливо
щоб кожна тварина почувалася комфортно
є ще дещо особлива у свинарника хейкеля
всі поросята тут із хвостами
[музика]
якщо хвіст бубликом то свині Почувається
добре Я знаю що вони щасливі
так щастить лише свиням у Фінляндії
у більшості європейських країн поросятам
відрізають хвости
розпеченими щипцями щоб свині не кусали
одна одній хвости
зоозахисники вже давно виступають проти
такого жорстокого способу ампутації
у фермерах гейкеля є простий засіб від
кусання хвостів
його свині мають достатньо місця та
іграшок
це гума але відчувається як хвіст
якщо ти як свиня відчуваєш потребу щось
зробити з зубами то можеш пожувати це
Ферма хейкеля знаходиться на півдні
Фінляндії він щорічно продає
відгодівельним комплексом понад 100
тисяч поросят і молодих свиней і
зізнається що раніше теж ампутував
поросятам хвости але з 2003 року у
Фінляндії це суворо заборонено які по
суті в усьому ЄС
Але у майже всіх інших державах членах
Союзу масово допускають винятки
це обурює також і тару антикайнин і
засоціації свинарів разом зі своїм
колегою хейкілем фінка бореться за
більшою Комфорт для тварин у
європейських свинарниках
свині відкушують собі хвости лише у
стані стресу
тож потрібні більші стайні і більше
різноманітності вона не погоджується з
тим що її європейські колеги
відмовляються від таких покращень і з
економічних причин
це завжди залежить від власного
ставлення Якщо ви з самого початку
скажете так не можна то так і буде слід
припинити завжди дивитися на витрати
треба зайняти позицію тварини замість
постійних думок про гроші
про те що деякі фермери у Фінляндії
більше турбуються про гроші ніж про
комфорт тварин ми дізнаємось у столиці
Гельсінки
захисники тварин із групи справедливість
постійно пробираються до ферм щоб
задокументувати страждання тварин
із хвостами бубликом чи без них у
багатьох місцях у Фінляндії свині часто
страждають
це так званий станок для опоросу
свиноматок
деякі з наших сусідніх країн заборонили
ці клітки але не Фінляндія
тварина можуть рухатися всередину лише
на кілька кроків вперед або назад
проблема не в тому що це незаконно А
якраз тому що це законно
зі своїми свинями у Фермер хейкеля так
Ніколи б не поводився
він не тільки стежить щоб у свиней було
достатньо місця але щоб його поросята не
мерзли Та не пітніли Для цього він
побудував власну систему вентиляції
ефект він перевіряє особисто
я ліг тут на півгоди і тоді я відчув
протяг
мені це не сподобалося
тому я розробив іншу систему вентиляцію
завдяки такій турботів вести поросят
фермера хейкеля скручуються в бублик
він не розуміє чому вже 30-річної
заборони на ампутацію не дотримується в
інших країнах членах ЄС
адже зрештою Це добре не лише для тварин
а й для фермерів
[музика]
якщо Ти отримуєш кращу продуктивність
тварин ти повернеш свої витрати
і ти можеш пишатися своїм виробництвом
і твою продукцію схвалюватиме
суспільство
у будь-якому разі у Фінляндії сприймають
лише свиней із закрученим бубликом
хвостом
найближчим часом ЄС хочу повернути
питання свинарства на порядок денний для
обговорення і щасливі поросята фермера
хейкеля можуть послужити у Європі
зразком
говорити пиво - це чоловіча справа чи не
так в Іспанії наперекірці і
загальноприйнятій думці працює все
більше жінок пивоварів зокрема
буставієго чи в його
там жінок об'єднує любов до пива та
бажання створювати нові сорти пива вони
кажуть що раніше пивоварінням в Україні
керували жінки А тепер Вони борються за
відродження цієї традиції
власниця крамниці Сусанна гінера
підтримує жінок пивоварів оскільки вона
постійно шукає нові сорти пива
на дінер пивна експертка в Барселоні У
неї є пивна крамниця і пивний бар її
особливість крафтове пиво її найбільша
любов пиво з жіночих рук
сьогодні пиво це делікатес Але раніше
його вважали їжею і готували його жінки
від Барселони до галісії на іншому кінці
Північної Іспанії Сусана шукає жінок
пивоварів та їхнє пиво для своєї
крамниці та блогу з акцентом на жіноче
пиво
[музика]
поблизу Віго Вона зустріла іззабель
vieitas
[музика]
скільки пива ти тут виробляєш я починала
з 250 літрів сьогодні вже понад 10 тисяч
літрів на місяць
я бачу себе професійним пивоваром і
підприємцем
свого успіху Я досягла сама
Ізабель почала шість років тому в той
час вона порушила винну традицію своєї
сім'ї зараз у Старому винному погребі
знаходиться сучасна та успішна пивоварня
крафтового пива
ізабельце вдалося Галіція брюжена
забаром з'явиться у крамниці сусани в
Барселоні
далі Дорога веде до Бустер в'їхав
гірського села 70 кілометрів на північ
від Мадрида
до бейліндера кооперативу чотирьох жінок
тут варять пиво архітекторка і
медіа-дизайнерка а також журналістка та
психологиня
усім чотирьом жінкам приблизно по 40
років
а вони кинули попередні професії заради
своєї пристрасті варіння пива
[музика]
ми хотіли працювати з нашими сім'ями у
місті де ми зараз живемо ми пробували
варити пиво ще вдома коли ми задумались
над заснуванням якогось підприємства
було зрозуміло це буде пивоварня жіноче
пиво процвітає завдяки натхненню та
свободі вибору інгредієнтів жінки
байляндера змішують у своєму пиві манго
чорницю і навіть квіти гібіскусу Сусана
варить своє пиво з великою кількістю
кориці бейліандера продає приблизно 45
тисяч літрів на рік вони та їхні сім'ї
можуть із цього добре жити у нас є також
бар який узимку вміщає 20 а влітку з
пивним садом 120 осіб у селі проживає
2500 жителів і зараз Ми створюємо з
Баром 9 постійних робочих місць включно
з нашими власними жінки які варять пиво
те що сьогодні здається екзотикою багато
століть в тому було повсякденним життям
адже пивоваріння раніше було не
чоловічою а здебільшого жіночою справою
оскільки жінка завжди займалась
господарством пекла хліб і варила також
пиво для сім'ї жінки продавали надлишки
на базарах зокрема і надлишки пива
особливо в 14 столітті через чорну чому
споживання пива різко зросло пиво тоді
було кориснішим та гігієнічнішим ніж
вода
хміль приніс великі зміни Завдяки йому
Пиво можна було зберігати а пивоваріння
стало супер бізнесом
жінок у безчистили як відьом що варять
пиво їх виганяли та спалювали
Це був також спосіб витіснити жінок із
бізнесу який став прибутковим
тож світ пива почали потроху
завойовувати чоловіки у монастирях або
на підприємствах виключаючи з цього
жінок
Сусанна виймає пивоварний солод з котла
через два місяці її пиво буде готове чи
хтось коли-небудь запитував вас що
шукають жінки опивоваріння так часто
тому для провокації Ми беремо з собою на
пивні ярмарки дошку на якій зображені
жінки з вусами серйозно так ми вам її
покажемо це жарт
де пивний майстер питають нас чому
майстри пивоваріння
ми жіноча пивоварня чорт забирай
жінки що варять пиво мають твердим намір
із гумором та комерційним чуттям знову
запанувати у пивоварінні
чи знаєте ви чим займаєтеся цілий день
почесний мир у кокінгтоні на заході
Англії його не завдання просто
створювати гарний настрій
він готовий до селфі любить
фотографуватися а також присутній на
відкритті шкіл і лікарні
тільки спромоми в нього не все так добре
тому що Патрік почесний мер чотири лапи
маленькі шотландський Поні і він досить
привабливий і Він просто любить обійми
для поні на службі в Англії заборонено
Алкоголь вочевидь не діє від нас на
сьогодні це все дякуємо від імені нашого
колективу за ваш інтерес і сподіваємося
на нову зустріч наступного тижня до
побачення
українською мовою звучано центром
медіініціатив переклад Володимира та
Олеся Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так
читали Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та
Олесь гоян Київ 2022 рік